return for ed miliband that's the one
big headline that from the completion of
Circus Thomas shadow cabinet the other
has to be really a purge of many Corbin
Easter's those loyal to mr. Corbin
now Ed Miliband takes on that business
brief that had been speculation he might
come back either to that or Shadow
Chancellor that's been taken as we know
yesterday by annalisa Dodds now the new
appointments are these David Lamia come
back for him shadow justice secretary
John Healy moves to shadow defense
secretary defense Healy that takes you
back doesn't it a long time ago
ed Miliband Emily Thornberry moves from
shadow foreign secretary to
international trade
Jonathan Reynolds Work and Pensions
Jonathan Ashford stays at health Rebecca
long Bailey a leadership candidate she
gets Angela rayna's old job of shadow
education secretary
I wonder if Angela Reyna had some
influence there Joe Stevens Digital
Culture Media and Sport Bridget Phillips
and new shadow chief secretary to the
Treasury Luke Pollard steps up
Environment Food and Rural Affairs Steve
Reed Communities and Local Government
Thangam debonaire housing jim mcmahon
transport praetor gil international
development louise hay temporarily
northern ireland now the reason for that
tony Lloyd the shadow Northern Ireland
secretary MP for Rochdale 70 years old
has been hospitalized labour says in
Manchester Royal Infirmary with the
coronavirus during this period Louise
Hague has been appointed interim shadow
Northern Ireland secretary Ian Murray a
deputy leadership candidate shadow
Scotland secretary near Griffith shadow
wells secretary Marcia DeCordova women
and equalities Andy McDonald a Corbin
Easter moves from transport to
employment rights and protections rizona
alençon another deputy leadership
candidate who are in the final round
came second to Angela Raina Shadow
Minister for mental health which I
believe is a new post
Kath Smith young people and voter
engagement Lord Faulkner stays Valerie
Vettel Vaz stays Nick Brown so that's
the new
it's now on the purge these are the
people who have left most have no not
all korban allies Tracy Bravin out
Richard Bergen Corbin Easter out dawn
Butler out Dan card announce church army
Chakrabarty out petered out gone
berry Gardner gone Margaret Greenwood
Andrew Gwen Barbara Keeley
Ian Lavery Rachel mascot Christina Reese
and John Trickett all gone labor say
this is a gender balance Shadow Cabinet
17 women 15 men seven ba ma members